mais le gros des banques l'année élus le
maire de la commune de saint cyr l'école
elle est la première femme à occuper la
fonction de maire dans l'histoire de
saint cyr l'école sonia bros 44 ans a
été élu avec 23 des 25 voix de la
majorité au conseil municipal de
bulletins blancs exprimer
l'ancienne première adjointe succède à
bernard de bain resté treize ans à la
tête de la commune c'est un grand
honneur c'est beaucoup de travail j'en
suis totalement consciente mais surtout
c'est un cheminement qui a qui a pris 10
ans et je remercierai jamais assez
monsieur de bain de m'avoir ouvert les
portes et de m'avoir appris le métier de
début de conseillère municipale puis
ensuite d'adjointe est aujourd'hui
dernière séance extraordinaire organisée
après la démission de bernard de bain 72
ans il a décidé de rendre son écharpe
obtenu en 2006 plusieurs raisons
avancées notamment celle de vouloir
profiter de sa famille l'ex maire reste
tout de même au conseil municipal comme
troisième adjoint on a presque un peu
l'impression qu'à la fin avant tout des
cas dans les derniers mois vous expédier
les affaires courantes et je trouve
qu'il était beaucoup mieux que la
personne qui va pouvoir se représenter
devant la population de la ville ça soit
celle qu'ils soient déjà aux commandes
une élection à laquelle n'a pas pris par
l'ensemble des élus des deux groupes
d'opposition de gauche a presque un an
du scrutin des municipales il dénonce
une opération électoraliste orchestrée
par la majorité le maire ne part porte
le seul poste qu'il a cédé et le poste
de
mr qu'il a cédé à sa première adjointe
qui sera candidate aux élections
municipales donc c'est vraiment une
manoeuvre précipiter
dans une lutte sans merci entre les
éléments différents de la droite saint
cyrienne référence au possible retour en
politique de l'ancien maire de droite
philippe lavaud démissionnaire en 2006
qui pourrait faire face à sonia bros aux
élections municipales en 2020